foreign
I have three mentors
so
anytime I think anytime I hit a little
dilemma in my life I write a really good
description of my dilemma before I reach
out to them because I don't want to
waste their time right right my mentors
or VIPs I don't want to waste a minute
of their time so so first I read a
really good description of the problem
and then I summarize it I summarize the
context the problem I summarize my
options and I summarize my thoughts
because I got to make this succinct I
don't want to send somebody a 20 Page
long email
so I have to make this as succinct as
possible what does that in practice look
like a half page page yeah half page
like it's like bullet points for
everything instead of paragraphs right
as succinct as it can and then before I
send it to them I try to predict what
this person would say so each of those
three right right what anybody would say
to this but yeah what this Mentor would
say with that Mentor would say I know
the way this guy thinks I've read all
his books I know the way and we've
talked a lot I know what he would say so
then I internalized that
and I address those points that I'm
predicting they would say I'm going to
address those in advance again to not
waste their time when you say dress them
what do you mean by that kind of like
how you asked I said something five
minutes ago and you asked me a question
like can you give me an example of that
or how do you know this so it's like
okay I knew you were going to ask that
so yeah here's my follow-up right so
I'll address those in advance again so
as not to waste their time
and then again one last time I tried to
predict okay well now that I've
addressed you have an answer ready for
whatever they might come back with but I
include it in the initial right summary
of your situation and then
after I've done that whole process I
don't need to bother with them anymore
because the answer is now clear because
I've just done the work yeah of
summarizing everything and imagining
what they would say so
the punchline is
the truth is I haven't talked to my
mentors in years
and one of them doesn't even know I
exist
these are my mentors and so this is how
I think it's kind of like Napoleon Hill
talked about the master behind or
whatever like he was like you know
imagine it Abraham Lincoln is there what
would Abraham Lincoln say totally so I
think that you're right I also get a lot
of emails from people saying like I need
a mentor will you Mentor me how do I
find a mentor and this is my answer like
it's all in your head it's about the
summarization of your situation thinking
of it from another person's point of
view You can predict what this person
would say if you're a fan of their books
and their podcasts and their talks you
know what they would probably say so do
it yourself
who is if you're willing to share the
person who doesn't know you exist it was
Tyler Cowan ah I just emailed him two
weeks ago to say thank you thanks for
your years of service for his continued
inspiration and he sent me back a tiny
little thanks
Seth Godin is one he knows exit we don't
talk that often but I very often think
like what would Seth Godin say he walks
the walk he's another example of someone
who walks the walk very much so yeah
not as common as he would hope no yeah
who's the third
it's actually changing I don't know
right now Keith Richards
Bjork what would you like cheese that
would be great but you know that's
they're really useful if you have a
fictional a fictional person can be your
Mentor yeah you know like what would
well [__] you know what would Jesus do
right yeah like people still do that
like okay I'm not sure what to do what
would Jesus do
that's a perfectly good Mentor
I think a lot of people would agree with
you and for those people who might
wonder I actually do something very
similar okay can you tell yeah
absolutely so I try to spend time with
people I I admire and aspire to be more
like in some capacity right because I do
think you become the people you spend
the most time with so to bring up a name
that we've already brought up I think
actually a lot about Matt Malinois
because he's very calm in almost all
circumstances not all I know what the
handful of things that bother him but
he's very very calm and measured
and good at
perspectival knowledge taking
alternative positions
taking the counter position on his own
thoughts his own opinions his own goals
so I often think when I get dysregulated
or upset about something I'm getting
wound up I'm like what would Matt do in
this what would Matt say to me if Matt
were in my shoes what would Matt do and
I've also done that in writing exercises
where I actually just sit down with my
older self oh wow who has figured it out
so if I'm talking to a version of myself
who's 10 years old or 20 years older who
has figured this out
what might that older wiser version of
me say
and I just write out the dialogue and by
the end I'm like huh
okay you know doesn't always give you
some magic solution but it is
astonishing how
often that will give you some type of
clarity or maybe relief
that helps you to cling less strongly to
whatever the challenge or problem or
question was that you had in mind it's
really remarkable
so I do something very similar I guess
that's what I'm saying sometimes even
just asking I get emails about once a
week where somebody
asks me a big question by email and then
at the end they say actually you don't
even really have to answer this just
honestly asking you the question helped
me get some clarity thank you yeah
totally yeah like just the act of
opening their email client and starting
with it and going okay I want to ask
Derek servers this thing yeah you know
it's like just even if I intend to reach
out to a mentor about something
I still go through the exercise of
trying to crystallize my thinking so I
don't waste their time even if it's a
really close friend like I don't if I
don't want to be lazy yeah right and I
don't want to ask them something that
could be resolved with five minutes of
Googling yeah right or five minutes of
introspection it's like whenever I go to
anyone I want you all to say
basically here's the situation
here are some of my assumptions here's
what I've already tried
like I've tried a b c d and e and I'm
not quite
figuring it out and then followed by a
super specific question but asking the
mentors around your imaginary table
and doing that homework I think is is
it's something that I do and I recommend
to everyone and there is some selfish
motive here like I would like to have
fewer than several thousand emails that
come in with like how can I launch my
book please tell me
and I'll admit I actually got
oddly shy two minutes ago when you asked
me who the third one was because
actually it's it's been you in the past
oh yeah and I
didn't want to bother you with things so
I'm just like I was tempted you know
I've got your phone number I could have
just texted you and I'm like no hold on
and I'll just do it for something never
mind
you know I think about you
I think about you Matt it's funny you
mentioned Seth because Seth would be on
a Shore list for me as well of people
who
really
think and more than think it's question
yeah right the musts the shoulds yeah
the have to's like wait a [__] second
that's nonsense you know I feel like
you're very good at that
which is part of the reason I've read uh
your first books many times
so now I'm all shy
hahaha